noi siamo per oggi
mi voglio inventare una cosa strana per
questa intro posso chiedervi se intanto
mita nate lieve lieve lieve un tipo una
cosa alla super quark
per la puntata di oggi di feroci abbiamo
deciso di prendere una virata improvvisa
a dare un colpo secco al timone cambiare
la rotta di un nostro viaggio che
continua a cercare di tracciare i
contorni dell'essere umano fa può
bastare comunque soltanto per dare un
mood torniamo quindi a navigare nelle
acque di un tema che non solo fa da casa
qualsiasi podcast abbiate mai ascoltato
ma che è colonna sonora della vita di
ognuno di noi la
parola rho la parola oggi abbiamo
invitato una persona che ha fatto della
comunicazione il proprio lavoro e che
con le parole riuscita a dire di tutto
siete curiosi di sapere di chi sto
parlando
assolutamente sì michele maio lo so già
perché sto parlando di riccardo pirrone
sto parlando di un digital strategist e
il pubblicitario di tav che per chi non
lo sapesse è l'azienda di pompe funebri
che ha fatto del black humour la sua
diciamo cifra stilistica segue anche uno
bravo che la piattaforma di psicologi on
line e rocchetta supporto delle donne
vittime di violenza predilige la piena
libertà di espressione e odia la censura
tema a noi molto caro per quella che
sarà la chiacchiera di oggi secondo lui
tutte le cose che funzionano passano per
il coraggio da questa sera un ragazzo
del iii michele bravi cose che
conosci di nemesi su di te quello
divertentissima
siami che le bravi chiedi che ora è ti
risponde che il tempo è di ritrovarsi
stessi nella propria individualità e
spiritualità ma anche nella relazione
con l'altro e quale era il proprio vero
è così
riccardo è un piacere averti qua in
serata si è gentilissimo innanzitutto
grazie dell'invito allora partiamo dalle
basi che lavoro fai come lo spiegheresti
a a tutti a tutti a tutti quegli stupidi
utenti che ci stanno seguendo
per dire
baroli realtà esatto no poverino
allora diciamo che per farci capire da
tutti sono il un pubblicitario quindi
creo pubblicità diciamo un po diverse da
quella che è la pubblicità tradizionale
perché sono più verticale sul digital
sul social quindi pubblicità online
cos'è che distingue un bravo brigitte
ario da un pessimo pubblicitario secondo
me un bravo pubblicitario riesce a
sintonizzarsi con quello che provano le
persone in quel determinato momento il
contesto storico
cioè significa che le pubblicità oggi
rispecchiano un po quelli che sono i
nostri problemi quelli che sono i nostri
bisogni desideri un pubblicitario deve
sapere cosa il suo target o comunque il
suo pubblico vuole e desidera in quel
momento
preciso adesso non voglio sembrare
arrogante però un qualche modo noi che
lavoriamo anche col social un polo
mastichiamo perché alla fine chi vive
nei social un po deve far pubblicità di
se stesso tutto ragazza personal brand
vivente che non so cosa vuol dire però
immagino che traducendo dall'inglese
vuol dire che sono il brand di successo
nel manager mio è un brand persona certo
perché lui ha dei valori che porta
avanti a un prezzo è un costo e sei un
bene di piri piri e consumabile quale ad
oggi attività che ti ha dato maggiore
soddisfazione mi viene in mente taf ora
non so se tutto l'asse perché io prima
di diventare un pubblicitario facevo
siti web quindi era un po nerd facevi
siti web siti web
scusate
lismo totale pensavo city cecità cd
accusatore no tranquillo tutto il
microfono così va che magari oggi
cornetto meglio se sto al contrario
prego ho creato il primo comparatore di
agenzie funebri vuoi dire cos'è il trip
advisor delle pompe funebri attivo
skyscanner tipo skyscanner quindi dai
scanner ok e da lì alessandro duff ha
visto questi articoli e mi ha chiamato
non siamo i primi che facciamo black
humour a fini commerciali
devo dire che la da fo è un caso
mondiale non è non esiste agenzia
funebre che ha 300 mila follower su
facebook
centocinquantamila su inter
insomma è davvero un caso quindi è un
incassarsi sotto vari punti di vista
riuscire a entrare all'interno di un
bisogno collettivo che magari quello di
esorcizzare un pochino quest'ansia pari
che ci portiamo dietro allo stesso tempo
quindi una roba che effetto domino porta
una serie di benefici anche economici
tutta questa visibilità si è tradotta
commercialmente nell'apertura del primo
franchising funebre viene naturale una
persona a rivolgersi allora in un
momento in cui io chiedo rispetto per il
mio dolore rivolgersi a una struttura
che ne cefa ironia di questa cosa
allora in realtà lo scrivono proprio sul
testamento alcuni già alcuni sono
talmente fidelizzati che vogliono erano
tappo e nessun altro una richiesta
preliminare
alcuni si è in realtà funzionano molto
sulla riconoscibilità del brand cioè è
l'unico brand che ricordi quando ti
capita questo tipo di cose che di solito
sono improvvise dico sempre che cosa
sono una piccola parte della pubblicità
nel senso che non è tutto il marketing
devono deve funzionare tutto deve
funzionare il prodotto il servizio è il
prezzo quando ti guardi attorno oggi
quanto la pubblicità per in giro cioè
abbiamo sempre di più abbiamo un rumore
continuo di spot tv radio giornali però
di base le persone credono sempre meno
la pubblicità cosa vuol dire credere
alla pubblicità però credere a quello
che ti dicono e quindi c'è la pubblicità
sta prendendo valore nel senso si è
tentato da disoccupato dice
probabilmente no perché cambia e
soprattutto oggi sta
evolvendosi a passare dalla
comunicazione
tradizionale che faceva sognare ad un
futuro migliore
ad una più relazionale nel senso che i
brand entrano in relazione con gli
utenti tu e tu e tu avrete dei brand che
amate e non vi spiegate il perché vi
piacciono col così tanto e quindi c'è
una certa
community che si che si crea intorno al
brand che questi brand diventano loft
brand ma voi ne avete qualcuno che ci
stavo tipo le gocciole sono a me ha la
prenda ma sono il tuo non prendo e
perché ti piaccio
e questo non c'è subito scorso si è
passati dalla allora del cambio
dentifricio colgate
e io non lo cambierò mai ma in realtà
guardo il prezzo e proprio
supermercato superando soldi sulle
commesse
cretino che sei il resto guarda che i
soldi liga crescono sull'albero a
guardarle offerte però non ho un brand
che dico c'è sulla moda già di più a
capitano ah scusate ma faccio una cosa
così grave siamo venute dalle offerte al
supermercato di cino pago di meno col
cazzo voglio pagare il doppio ma non ho
capito se sì sofferto ci sono le
gocciole le prendo se non certo ci sono
i pan di stelle prendo comunque
questa è la bre a un brand sulla parte
dei profilattici usa sempre lo stesso
brand ma perché quello è più
prestazionale
[Risate]
in realtà credo di avere un look brand
che se letti anche mi piace un sacco
però non ho niente di seletti
qualcosa se questo è ancora meglio
perché vuol dire che lo adora tornerò
senza motivo occorre un motivo che non
sai in realtà oggi molti brand stanno
sposando delle cause sociali e semplice
nike on high key to diresti mai kayhan
che
lotta da tanto tempo contro la violenza
della polizia nella nei confronti della
comunità afroamericana questo ha
risuonato molto nella pubblicità ma
anche nei media quindi questa cosa che
la nai chi si espone anche al rischio di
perdere i clienti e di perdere una fetta
di mercato per questa esposizione
potrebbe essere rischiosa per loro
tantissimo e io
un'esposizione umanitaria però è ma
tutta la comunità bianca che non
votazioni con quella parte quindi c'è un
mondo il proprio cuore a chi c'era c'è e
io mi ricordo questa cosa pubblica era
successo di quel giocatore di football
chi non si era
c'entrava mike e questo proprio come
testimoni giallo simbolo di quella
protesta e poi c'è stata una rivolta da
parte dei fans che hanno buttato le loro
scarpe nike nike i
quindici assurdo allo stesso modo io ho
una
riprendo barilla scusami
perché in passato sono state fatte delle
affermazioni per esempio su quella che
secondo loro era
tutti rientrano interni con la roba
comprassero altre passate sia la lettera
diciamo che tutti i brand e si stanno
spostando sul brand activism e quindi
spostando delle cause importanti per le
loro community che lo fanno perché così
ci arriva il mese del pride arcobaleni
bravissimo allora ho messo questa maglia
proprio per dirti che schumi don termini
significa aperto mostrami quello che fai
esa si sono per sensibilizzare per
promuovere un cambiamento per risolvere
un problema che attanaglia tutti don
termino raccontarmelo e basta come
gestisci in questo momento quello che
viene definito l'eccessivo moralismo
rispetto al mondo pubblicitario no
quante volte adesso si sentono delle
campagne che magari sono un po infelici
su alcune cose però poi diventano un
caso di d
macchina di fango che alimentano l'odio
verso un brand quindi intende shift
stompers umbra esatto possono capitare
girando per chiedere di come si
gestiscono le crisi le crisi ma
soprattutto sai cosa sai quante volte
adesso si dice a questa cosa non si può
dire anche se fa ridere questa cosa non
la possiamo dire perché offende quella
categoria quest'altra offende l'altra
sottocategoria difficile fare il
pubblicitario oggi perché devi stare
attento a tante cose ma forse difficile
anche fare l'artista oggi di base è
difficile tutto perché dobbiamo stare
attenti a tante persone che hanno varie
sensibilità e finalmente siamo diventati
più evoluti e quindi per muoverci quindi
per dare dinamismo alla nostra società
bisogna avere anche accortezze quindi
anche noi pubblicitari dobbiamo averle
c'è la regola ancora dell'importante è
che se ne parli e è vera in pubblicità
in parte vera in parte no cioè quante
delle sci delle citt storm che posso
possiamo aver visto negli ultimi anni
sono volute
[Musica]
la regola del l'importante è che se ne
parli io sono un brand allora dico
faccio la cosa che so che mi certo
vabbè ma ragazzi ma scusate come se io
dovessi vendere un disco è ovvio che se
salgo sul palco di sanremo e calcinate
tande faccio vedere le mie natiche so
che se ne parlerà con la male
ma non mi ha risposto sai rispondere
allora quante non lo so sicuramente
dipende dal livello del brand a che
punto sta della sua vita po come è
successo con buondì motta quando ha
fatto cadere l'asteroide su tutta la
famiglia no ho amato è e tu hai amato da
molti no c'è stata una scelta
certo perché comunque è ammazzata
bambina il
padre troppo facile perché prendeva e
distruggeva a quel discorso del
buongiorno che cosa vuoi qualcosa
buonissima
s e comunque si ritorna sempre alla
persona disturbata dai allora secondo te
ad oggi esistono
dei tabù o c'è o esiste un modo per
poter parlare di tutto se solo se
riuscissi a trovare la chiave ho sentito
tempo fa non so chi è che diceva un
comico bravo riesce a parlare di tutto
se tu dice che non si può più dire
niente vuol dire che non sei quello così
bravo da poterlo esprimere quindi forse
una via c'è sempre per riuscire a
esprimere dei contenuti che
all'apparenza sembrano tabù qual è la
vostra pubblicità preferita della vita
allora io sono affezionato tutto il
mondo pubblicità col jingle liborio
casoni
ammoniaca detergente super profumo e le
conosciamo tutti quelle cose lì è un po
italiano la conosco perché tu sei
piccolo io credo che tra le mie
pubblicità preferite ci siano sia tipo
air action vigorsol ma sempre fatto
molto ridere l'ho sempre trovato molto
molto intelligente vi ricordate quando
ero piccolo di quelli nana non
bastino mini le colle vis che la salvava
da un palazzo in fiamme avevo tipo 6 6 7
anni la guardavo la trovo e ci
tantissima super sexy e la volevo rifare
con un mio compagno che convinceva a
togliersi i jeans e poi fare il bacio
alla fine tipo facciamo una pubblicità è
ma alla fine si baciano ma questo perché
sei mani ago non perché la pubblicità
una delle mete al c'è non preferite però
che mi ricorderò per sempre è quella di
red bull c'è red bull ti mette le ali
sempre tutti che si rifacevano anas tra
belli le più belle il payoff fighissimo
il flop ti mette le ali il pay off è la
frase che accompagna il logo ultimate le
ali sì quello è chiaro tipo quale
potrebbe essere il mio del mio brand
michele bravi
a tuo agio da michele bravi dolce ma non
troppo cioè con un po di sofferenza
capito perché una dicotomia del fondo
quale mi piaceva più questi gare bravi
dicotomia de fondo di chi non vuol dire
un cazzo
ricercato lollo barolo il tuo play off
sarebbe e lollo barollo ma non mollo e
certo darà una mano modo ci sta bello
pure lollo bar o no bara romano lollo
che
ma baragazza vogliamo scilla guglielmo
scilla e lana le
viene
viene invece la vostra pubblicità nella
pubblicità che vede più odiato igiene o
una rasa il pratino ma quelle fighissima
le più belle io guerra sembrati rasa il
pratino avevo dei conati di vomito
mentre non viene ora che c'è non è che
odio però mi rimarrà per sempre in testa
cosa che fa mamma o un luce o leggero
prurito intimo lei usava gisin
ma in realtà pubblicità che non mi
piacciono non me le ricordo mi ricordo
soltanto quelle comunque mondo jingle
musicali che proprio ti trapana mano il
cervello cioè tipo chi chi chi chi chi
pulisce 10 una roba dice che mi
affascina punto la oti però di base è
incredibile
rimangono in testa pure perché le senti
milioni di volte quindi proprio il tipo
le hit estive se tu hai detto è che
tutte le cose funzionano che funzionano
passano per il coraggio il coraggio
perché per sondare nuovi stili di
comunicazione nuovi linguaggi nuove
costrutti devi tentare di saltare in un
posto dove nessuno è mai stato se non
faccio un posto dove non c'è almeno un
commento negativo in easy voce non ho
detto niente di importante
certo noi non dobbiamo fare la
pubblicità
dobbiamo fare quello che in tivù è
chiamato spettacolo io trovo un pochino
terrificante il fatto che tutto debba
essere creatività c'è cazzo fai
pubblicità che sia solo pubblicità no
deve essere spettacolo creatività storia
messaggio 50 quanta creatività si
disperde su così questo però un
atteggiamento snob dove per l'unica
creatività e quelli che si fa con la
lira campano avanti a 13 ma smettila
rincon
versione di creatività che anche
l'utente smette di percepirla come tale
ci sono degli spot che sono state opere
d'arte
in questa modalità qua dove tutto quello
che comunichi e riflessione creativa
smette anche il pubblico diserzioni
altre 600 recherà aspetta io facevo
servito su intendi per una persona
creativa noi allora il discorso parte a
prescindere quanto è svilente il fatto
che devi mettere una creatività per
vendere una creatività o capitano
sentendo io ti dirò che invece trovo più
svilente il fatto che io veda invece
dietro a tantissime opere creative molta
più strategia cioè non vedo e gli
artisti vedo dei calcolatori e quindi
stiamo dicendo che le persone come te
stanno rovinando il mondo ma in realtà
anche come te no in realtà come il
perché
frena il mondo come michele brani no
però in generale c'è quello non per me
non vuol dire svendersi quello vuol dire
essere consapevoli di essere un prodotto
ma ci sono però persone che sono ancora
meno sono un prodotto prodotto prodotto
da calcio devo sentire
scassato il cazzo mostra cosa possiamo
continuare grazie
eravamo per dire dal punto che lui
diceva la creatività è sprecata per la
pubblicità non aspettino problema è che
la voce anche per noi la usano cioè nel
senso che è proprio quello che dà il
sale a un prodotto a un servizio ha
usato l'immagine giusta nota il sale
alle cose per quanto mi riguarda in
questo momento il condimento è talmente
tanto che mi sono dimenticato del sapore
originale lo ha spiegato bene
cosa cazzo di
bravo il sale allora
in realtà ho seguito dall'inizio alla
fine anche io che ho capito
esatto
0 lo avevamo appena detto lollo barolo
ma non mollo malolos con noi ci ha persi
almeno 20 minuti no ma perché michele
dice la creatività è troppo centrale il
cervello con questa penna michele tutti
si
non so che cazzo dici sinceramente non
lo è interrotto un momento di confronto
fra i tre adulti che stavano questo
certo per battere i piedi è capito e
dire e io io io dove sono prego
lara
[Musica]
oggi senso
la pubblicità
da quanto tempo fai questo lavoro la
velocità è cambiata negli anni ragazzi
che epoca ti piace di più della
pubblicità
credo che è sempre la stessa è cambiato
giusto il mezzo perché mentre prima era
web prima ancora era cartaceo oggi è più
social quindi cambiano lì secondo me si
aspettava una risposta tipo rosa e la
fase della belle epoque
no ma la pubblicità sui social per
esempio funziona più che quella sulla
tv funziona in maniera differente sui
social voglio raggiungere degli
obiettivi che non sono gli stessi che
voglio raggiungere con la tv o con la
radio o con la stampa e soprattutto
raggiungo un target differente se fare
una domanda alla michele bravi e
allora trasliamo tutto questo nel campo
del sentimento no perché la pubblicità a
tutti gli effetti un atto manipolatorio
perché il sentimento
[Musica]
cosa il sentimento della pubblicità è un
atto manipolatorio andiamo nel campo dei
sentimenti tu sei pubblicitario anche
nella tua vita
allora o che come rispondi perché sei
stato bravissimo fino adesso due secondi
diventi un manipolatore dalla domanda
chissà se sono manipolatorio anche nella
mia vita personale
in realtà non sono così bravo come
quando faccio il pubblicitario per la
verità questa è la prima regola dei
manipolatori
screditare se stessi perché abbassi la
guardia fa bravo allora io ti avrei
conosciuto
sul dissidio cielo già cascato e roccia
a comprare
è ok quindi se il manipolatorio nella
vita come funziona è un indole cai del
resto sin da quando eri piccolo e nel
dover ve lo diciamo che io quando faccio
il pubblicitario cerco di far apprezzare
il prodotto servizio a che li vedi come
ha già spostato
michele tranquillini magari faccio la
stessa cosa anche con me cerco di
rendermi desiderabile
e quindi magari faccio in modo tale che
quella persona
riesca a percepire delle qualità che a
lui piacciono in me il tuo compito è
quello di trovare le parole giuste per i
of giusti e tour compagnia bella ci sono
stati momenti nei quali invece le parole
non se riusciamo a trovarne la tua vita
ma in realtà io più che non le trovo mi
blocco perché io sono un ex balbuziente
cui davvero ma diciamo che il mio
problema è stato pure il mio punto di
forza perché quando alle medie alle
superiori mi bloccavo dovevo sostituire
quelle parole con dei sinonimi
oggi questo bagaglio di termine lo uso
nel mio mestiere quindi o un'infinità di
parole differenti da quelle che
normalmente uso per magari utilizzarle
per delle frasi per le copie del tuo
modo diciamo di girare attorno allo
stato la sise si blocca quella parola lì
la sostituisco come uno che non si
blocca e anche oggi ho questo spettro
che potrebbe succedere ma su ogni tanto
succede tipo adesso ma succede a tutti è
rialzato di 15 persone da un organo
valore una valenza diversa per me è tipo
la cosa più grave che ho fatto che ha
vinto però allo stesso tempo questa qui
è giustamente una storia di una persona
che nel cercare di trovare le parole
giuste per esprimersi in realtà trovato
le parole giuste per permettere un sacco
di altre persone di esprimersi prova
ridirlo alla michele bravi team santo
michele questo è tosta perché aiutami tu
in realtà perché io l'ho detta allora è
la storia di un bambino mi crederebbe un
bambino bambino che nel cercare di non
inciampare sulle parole ed è che la sta
imboccando finiscila la sala di un
bambino che nel cercare di non
inciampare sulle parole è riuscito a
[Musica]
impastarli per far saltare il mondo su
quelle parole
ammazzo pubblicitario
cardino para come un paraculo
qualcuno le a impastare queste parole
io direi che siamo veramente arrivati
alla fine di questa di questa
chiacchiera quale è tra le varie cose ci
siamo detti oltre le cose che non sono
state erette un messaggio un qualcosa
che vorresti dirci diciamo che dobbiamo
se volete puntare
all'evoluzione e quindi chiunque voglia
fare il pubblicitario il social media
manager deve superare i suoi limiti e le
sue sovrastrutture anche attraverso la
psicologia per essere più libero di
esprimersi hashtag iscrivetevi uno bravo
all star e manipolatorie incesti
morirete tappo vabbè io ho chiesto
qualcosa di onesto e di sincero
visitare prestiti pubblicitari vabbè
ragazzi che dire
ricardo grazie alla sensibilità davvero
poi siamo arrivati alla fine di questa
tratta il male stasera è calmo ma la
prossima puntata mostra già nuvole
cariche di pioggia all'orizzonte
lasciamo le nostre spalle un mare vasto
complesso ma tutti noi familiare per
muoverci verso queste acque più profonde
e ricordate acque che nascondono i
nostri vizi le nostre dipendenze le
storie sommerse di migliaia di persone
che nel giro di qualche minuto sono
passate dalla cresta dell'onda al fondo
più poi era male da una feroce
e rifaccio quest'ultima frase perché
verso e te non sa leggere io
l'ho scritta non
c'è
chiaramente in barca però scusate
sentite ra letta così leggi lama fa
schifo il mare stasera è calmo ma la
prossima puntata mostra gianlu vole
cariche di pioggia all'orizzonte
lasciamo le nostre spalle infatti un
mare vasto complesso ma tutti noi
familiare per muoverci verso acque più
profonde
acque che nascondono i nostri vizi le
nostre dipendenze e le storie sommerse
di migliaia di persone che nel giro di
qualche minuto sono passate dalla cresta
dell'onda al fondo più buio del ma come
mise en polluce speravo proprio parola
per le feroci e tutto ragazzi e ragazze
un graffio
io posso dire mi avete fatto vedere
ragazzi con quest ultimo commento
sgradevole che c'è il discorso di
autoanalisi suoi scrivere altro analisi
[Musica]